[Music]
what if i told you
that today
you'll leave here
different
wow
i'm talking
to you
bro what you see someone above the
clouds that's big i'll be big
you think whatever kill pops is out
there
[Music]
right here
you
are going to witness
an absolute spectacle
[Music]
so what happens next
are you ready
are you ready
[Music]
here we go
i'm talking rich and famous for life
there's plenty of videos for flying [ __ ]
online ain't nobody gonna get what we
gonna get we gonna get the money shot
what's up undeniable proof of aliens on
camera
the oprah shot
you guys gonna tell me what's going on
hell no
it's aliens
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
i'll be rooting for you
i think we pissed them off yeah they
repainted your house
they gonna come back
ready
we got some work to do
nope i'll get him out
[Music]
and i'll get the shot let's go baby
let's go
i need you to tell me what did you see
in that cloud
[Music]
was not what you think
they took me
they took them all
i gotta get
let's dream you're
chasing we end up at the top of the
mountain
it's the one you never wake up from
you'll be getting a call from my
supervisor asking how my service was
five stars angel five stars
[Music]
you